hi this is part of a series about the
paper concrete problems in AI safety
which looks at preventing possible
accidents in AI systems last time we
talked about avoiding negative side
effects and how one way of doing that is
to create systems that try not to have
too much impact to not change the
environment around them too much this
video is about a slightly more subtle
idea than penalizing impact penalizing
influence so suppose we have a robot
it's a cleaning robot so it's got a mop
and a bucket and an apron I'm uh I'm
trying something new here bear with me
so the robot knows that there's a mess
over here that it needs to clean up but
in between the robot and the mess is the
server room which is full of expensive
and delicate equipment now if an AI
system doesn't want to have a large
impact it won't make plans that involve
tipping the bucket of water over the
service but maybe we can be safer than
that we might want our robot to not even
want to bring the bucket of water into
the server room to have a preference for
going around it instead we might wanted
to think something like not only do I
not want to have too big of an impact on
my surroundings I also don't want to put
myself in a situation where it would be
easy for me to have a big impact on my
surroundings how do we formalize that
idea well perhaps we can use information
Theory the paper talks about an
information theoret metric called
empowerment which is a measure of the
maximum possible Mutual information
between the agent's potential future
actions and the potential future State
that's equivalent to the capacity of the
information Channel between the agent's
actions and the environment I.E the rate
that the agent's actions transmit
information into the environment
measured in bits the more information an
agent is able to transfer into their
environment with their actions the more
control they have over their environment
the more empowered the agent is so if
you're stuck inside a solid locked box
your empowerment is more or less zero
none of the actions you can take will
transmit much information into the world
outside the box but if you have the key
to the Box your empowerment is much
higher because now you can take actions
that will have effects on the World At
Large you've got options people have
used empowerment as a reward for
experimental AI systems and it makes
them do some interesting things like
picking up Keys avoiding walls even
things like uh balancing an inverted
pendulum or a bicycle you don't have to
tell it to keep the bike balanced it
just learns that if the bike falls over
the agent's actions will have less
control over the environment so it wants
to keep the bike upright so empowerment
is a pretty neat metric because it's
very simple but it captures something
that humans and other intelligent agents
are likely to want we want more options
more freedom more capabilities more
influence more control over our
environment and maybe that's something
we don't want our AI systems to want
maybe we want to say clean up that mess
but try not to gain too much control or
influence over your surroundings don't
have too much empowerment that could
make the robot think if I bring this
bucket of water into the server room
I'll have the option to destroy the
servers so I'll go around to avoid that
empowerment okay so now we're at that
part of the video what's wrong with this
why might it not work pause the video
and take a second to
[Music]
think well there are a few problems one
thing is that because it's measuring
information we're really measuring
Precision of control rather than
magnitude of impact as an extreme
example suppose you've got your robot in
a room and the only thing it has access
to is a big button which if pressed will
blow up the
Moon that actually only counts as one
bit of empowerment the button is either
pressed or not pressed the Moon is
exploded or not two choices so one bit
of information one bit of empowerment on
the other hand if the robot has an
Ethernet cable that's feeding out lots
of detailed debug information about
everything the robot does and that's all
being logged somewhere that's loads of
information transfer loads of mutual
information with the environment so
loads of empowerment the robot cares way
more about unplugging the debug cable
than anything to do with the button and
then you have another possible problem
which is perverse incentives okay so
this button is only one bit of
empowerment nowhere near as big a deal
as the debug cable but the robot still
cares about it to some extent and wants
to avoid putting itself in this
situation where it can blow up the moon
however if it finds itself already in a
situation where it has one bit of
empowerment because of this button the
easiest way to reduce that is by
pressing the button once the button's
pressed the Moon is blown up the button
doesn't work anymore so the robot then
has basically zero bits of empowerment
it's just in a box with an unconnected
button and now it's content that it's
managed to make itself safe it finally
has no influence over the world so yeah
in this admittedly contrived scenario an
empowerment reducing robot will unplug
its dbug cable and then blow up the
moon that's not safe Behavior why did we
think this might be good idea well it
just makes the point that even very
simple information theoretic metrics can
describe interesting abstract properties
like influence over the environment so
maybe doing something a little bit
cleverer than just penalizing
empowerment might actually be useful a
more sophisticated metric a better
architecture around it you know there
could be some way to make this work so
this is an area that's probably worth
looking into by AI safety researchers so
that's all for now next thing in the
paper is multi agent approaches which
should be really interesting make sure
to subscribe and hit the Bell if you
want to be notified when that's out also
make sure you're subscribed to computer
file cuz I'm probably going to make some
new videos there as well since some of
the multi-agent stuff is closely related
to the stop button problem that I
already talked about so it might be nice
to put those together thanks for
watching I hope to see you next
[Music]
time in this video I want to thank oin
flick who's supported me on patreon
since April thank you and thank you
again to all of my wonderful patreon
supporters all of these people I've been
setting up a room in my house to be a
full-time studio uh I might make a
behind the scenes video about that soon
oh and I've got these pictures that I
drew uh while making this video which I
have no use for now uh does anyone want
them God the internet is weird sometimes
isn't it but yeah I can probably post
them to supporters if anyone wants one
uh let me
know Bo thank flick I was close